Speaker 1: If I told you folks in my audience,
Donald Trump called a Wisconsin official to try
to overturn the election results. That would
not be the most surprising headline, right?
You would say, well, we know he called Georgia and
we know he was doing funny business with Arizona.
It's not really surprising that he called
Wisconsin as well. Sure. What is surprising
is Trump called a Wisconsin official last week to
try to overturn the results. This is not a repeat.
It's July of 2022. The election was in November of
2020. Donald Trump called the Wisconsin official
last week to continue trying to overturn the
election, and when the official was not into
Trump's requests, he went untruth, set the truth
central, truth social. He went on truth social
and started calling the guy a RINO. All right.
So let's look at this. This is Assembly Speaker
Robin Vos, who is interviewed and says Trump
called me last week to try to overturn and
change the results in Wisconsin. Look at this.
Speaker 2: Once I started talks. The former
president, President Trump was in last week and
the last week before after he tweeted about it
before. What was that conversation like? It was
one of those that it's very consistent. He makes
his case, which I respect. He would like us to do
something different in Wisconsin. I explained that
it's not allowed under the Constitution. He has
a different opinion and he put the tweet out. So
listen to that.
Speaker 1: Listen. He calls me. He
tells me what he wants me to do, which I respect.
And then I explain to him it's unconstitutional.
Why would you respect Trump trying to strongarm
you into doing something that's unconstitutional,
that's not worthy of respect? And I guess Robin
Vos is, you know, trying to mince words here a
little bit. What is to be respected about a
former president demanding unconstitutional
action? And case in point, I believe Robin Vos
told Trump on the phone, Yeah, we can't do that,
because then Trump took to Truth Social
and attacked Robin Vos, saying, quote,
Looks like Speaker Robin Vos, a long time
professional RINO always looking to guard as flank
will be doing nothing about the amazing Wisconsin
Supreme Court decision stating loud and clear
that the impossible to control ballot unlock
boxes in the state are illegal. What a waste
of a brilliant and courageous decision by
Wisconsin's highest court. The Democrats
would like to sincerely thank Robin and all of
his fellow RINOs for letting them get away with
murder a rigged and stolen election. Now, I want
to remind people in the audience who may have
forgotten or maybe you don't know. There is no
such thing as decertification. Donald Trump's goal
is or Donald Trump's belief maybe is that
if there is a court ruling that says, oh,
these ballot boxes were improperly used, that you
can decertify the election. Now, first of all,
you can't, because those very boxes had a mix
of Biden and Trump ballots in them. And there is
absolutely no way to even demonstrate that those
specific boxes favored one candidate or another.
But we're already in Beyond Fantasy because
there's no such process as decertification.
Stephen Bannon has been talking about this
for a year. He'll casually say on his show,
Oh, we're moving to decertify Arizona. Oh, wow.
Jeez, that sounds pretty serious. There is no such
process as decertification. Like, what does Trump
think will happen? A state will say, we decertify.
Biden is the winner. And then Biden's kicked
out of the White House and Trump is ushered in.
There is no such process. The election
ended 20 months ago. Biden was sworn in
18 months ago and there are very few ways in
which Biden leaves early. And in none of those
situations, this Trump become the president. If
Joe Biden dies, Kamala Harris becomes president.
They don't go back and say, Sir, Trump, come back.
It doesn't happen. Number two, Joe Biden resigns.
Kamala Harris becomes president,
not Donald Trump. Number three,
Congress impeaches and convicts Joe Biden. Forcing
him out of office. Kamala becomes president,
not Donald Trump. 25th Amendment is used if
the Cabinet believes the president cannot
carry out their duties. They can invoke the 25th
Amendment. Biden's removed. Kamala Harris becomes
president of the United States, not Donald Trump.
So there is no such prior. Think about the layers.
There's no evidence that a decertification
should take place in any state.
Even if there was evidence there is no process
for decertification doesn't exist. And even.
Speaker 2: If.
Speaker 1: You were able to through a process
that exists, like resignation, impeachment, death
of a president, 25th minute remove the president,
it doesn't go to Donald Trump. It goes to
the vice president. So it is three or four
layers removed from reality. Last week, Trump
tried to get the Wisconsin results overturned.
It's crazy. Check out the clip on our Instagram,
which you can find at David Pakman show.